have you ever done any events where you
meet your fans or anything like that
um yes i have um i i'm in this uh
like a uh vocal dance unit called prima
porta
okay and um uh we had like this thing
called watashikai where we
like hand the cds to uh the
people who bought the cds right right
and um yeah we were able to like talk to
um the fans um for like 30 seconds a
minute
right now there's a speed run there yeah
really sweetie
but yeah yeah is it kind of like the
same thing as in like with like
i know a lot of the water sky with like
idols for instance that's the
handshaking event yeah but
the time extends depending on how many
cds you bought oh we
didn't have that it was kind of like um
hierarchy
yeah did you have to do a handshaking
thing as well oh no we didn't do
hatching it was more like
um waving and just talking like
you know waving in close proximity well
i saw videos of like guys
not letting go and like security oh yeah
i guess it's so scary
yeah definitely is it is it weird like
when the first time that you had to do
that
is it a weird feeling to be like wow
these people came for me
yeah it feels really like because
because you know like
like on the internet like sns like you
don't know how many people are actually
like
into you like i mean they might comment
and stuff like that but you don't know
like if they're really really like
you know yeah yeah yeah we feel the same
yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then so when you actually go
and like meet people and they're like oh
my gosh i've been wanting to meet you
for like so long you like you're like
i'm so glad i did this job
being able to meet all those people and
um even if you can't like talk to
everyone just
seeing them and like you know when
you're like when you attend events and
stuff and they're like calling out your
name it's like
like like you know you feel really happy
so like for me you're doing it yeah
for me yeah yeah oh my gosh you're the
best mate yeah
that's not so fun do you go too many
events then i've seen now i imagine it's
yeah yeah yeah but um yeah i
like before like this all happened like
yeah i used to like attend events pretty
often
and have you been on the other side like
like uh
yes i actually have like before going
into this industry like
um i'll buy tickets to like concerts and
lives and i'll be like buy the cds i'll
buy the cds and i'll buy the goods
yeah he waved at me
it'd be really awkward if you turn up to
the voice session they'd be like why do
i know you
it was funny because one time um i went
to like a um
concert and um it was like a female
voice actors concert
and like her fans were like mostly male
but i really liked her so like i went
there by myself
and um all the fans were like male right
so like it'll be like one girl and all
these males and
because i think they thought that it was
really rare that a girl would
come to that concert they were kind of
like um
to me like oh um if i get too like noisy
using the like
the blades like please let me know like
sorry let me put away
i felt the exact same way when i went to
the the sailor moon museum
oh like because it was like like five
years ago
in the mori arts museum yeah and they
had a sailor
moon museum and i was like i [ __ ]
love sailor moon
imagine a room full of just like tiny
like
japanese girls like falling over sailor
moon meanwhile in the middle of it
there's this massive
white dude just being like that's so
[ __ ] cute oh my god dude i [ __ ]
love mercury
i felt i've never had so many women
stare at me for all the whole problems
this is the weirdest experience
what am i not allowed to like sailor
moon [ __ ] you